[Music]
[Applause]
one of the members of our studio
audience Carol is a nurse and she came
up to look at Todd's injury that was
very sweet of her to yes it was and it
sounds like everything's good no
amputation don't need any shots you
don't rooting for me to like lose my leg
though I can't I'm working with you like
over 20 years you're like maybe they'll
take your leg off and you could limp oh
my but is that good content for the show
that's good content I know deep down you
I don't think you would mean that that
you'd want me to uh stop being so
selfish to yeah why don't you give back
to the show lose a leg give back to the
show I got Carol's number in case
this that's not why you have Carol's
number dud that's nobody's business
between me and Carol that's between me
and Carol yeah he wanted to know about
her bedside Manner and not the bedside
manner you're thinking is you know what
tell you something in priv yeah you
can't do that I heard you say you have
very good bedside I did that didn't mean
anything like she had that BR muser is a
whole uh and he's going to be busy this
weekend uh he's going to be uh the
countdown to kickoff with Brent
Musburger in uh airing Sunday mornings
at noon Eastern on Vis
vs N the sports betting Network you can
find out more
vs.com let's welcome in Brett
mburger
Man by the group is here look at this
you got a live audience oh
my a lty holy lad lad how are you hi
buddy you got the whole gang here yeah
we brought microphone sponsored by
Mercedes wow that's great we got it all
yeah got to pay for this trip Brent
listen how about this crowd it's awesome
awesome if I would have told you 10
years ago we're having a Super Bowl in
Vegas you would have said what I would
have left yeah how did we get
here well the Supreme Court brought us
here when they um when they
legalize gambling on Sports the NFL
realizes we got to embrace this in some
manner because otherwise it could get
out of our control for example let me
let me give you a prop you can't bet on
this week
okay the number of yellow flags that
will be thrown the NFL insisted with
DraftKings FanDuel all the rest and uh
we stay away from the officiating and
they agreed to do that otherwise
offshore you were always able to bet how
many penalties how many holding calls
you know things like that so the NFL
became part of it and now gambling's a
big sponsor the other side of it is uh
Jerry Jones the owner of the Cowboys he
helped Mark Davis get the Raiders in
here and then Mark main who was in
working with the Raiders built this
beautiful Stadium Alle Legion and uh the
rest is history Mark and Jerry lobbied
the league and uh and here we are with a
Super Bowl in Las Vegas what made the
commissioner kind of change his opinion
he was worried about the Integrity of
the sport what has changed to ensure the
Integrity of this sport I think you have
to stay close with it now and most of
the betting as as your audience knows
because some of them do you bet on your
phones you know it's it's all the apps
that you go to in the old days we used
to come out here
and my buddy Jimmy the Greek we would go
to the barbery
coast and stand in line at a window and
I said Greek how come you always come to
the barbery coast he said Brent because
in parlays ties win okay
so so now now the Greek and I we would
you know we just like I do I use the
phone cuz I live here in Las Vegas and
have the different apps with the casinos
but and you know you're tracked I mean
everybody everybody's got a cell phone
yeah so you get ads that come your way
based upon what you're looking at I mean
the technology is unbelievable tracks
you where you are knows all things about
you and so listen they know about every
Gambler who comes on board whether he's
the $20,000 better or the $20 better
they know what's the most you bet on a
football game on a single
game and a Greek and I maybe 5,000 okay
yeah but that's back in the 70s that you
bet five grand yeah when see that was in
the 80s okay good story so the
Eagles coached by dick verm are playing
play in the Raiders owned by Al
Davis and you should know I think I've
told you about this before the Greek and
Al Davis were the closest of friends I
don't ever remember Jimmy coming on the
NFL today without having talked to Al
either on Saturday night or Sunday
morning they're getting The Latest Scoop
okay around the league so Al said to
Jimmy we were down in New Orleans and he
said uh Greek you call him Greek
Eagles aren't fast enough to stay with
us they don't have enough speed and Al
was a speed guy that's what made the
Raiders in the early days so this is the
Super Bowl Ron jorski against the
Raiders Rod Martin Rod Martin okay you
remember him all and
Jaws so the Greek the Greek came how
much money can you raise okay ra I said
well let me let me go around and see so
I I think I was collecting five bills
from somebody that we get did together
it was no contest I mean the uh Raiders
got it on top and and took it home and
it was it was an easy I think it was the
biggest win of the Greeks life uh that
sounds like insider trading there Brent
is what that
does you know to that point the
Integrity of the game insider trading
that's why the NFL has always been the
best of all the pro leagues about
injuries injuries are critical
information for betters okay I was asked
by somebody yesterday I was over at
Circa at the VN studio and I was ask
how's KD's toe I said well I'm assuming
it's going to be okay because they
have't but we won't get our first injury
report until today today is actually the
first practice day uh for the Niners and
uh the Chiefs we're talking to Brett
musberger the Hall of Famer you've had
this incredible career uh you're part of
the reason why I got in this business
because I saw what you were doing I
didn't know how to get there but you
were talking football you had people on
the set and and then you started hosting
a lot of different things but were you
at the were you poolside with Joe Neo at
the fountain blue in Miami when he made
the prediction yeah I sure was now
you're a reporter in Chicago I am
correct Chicago's American okay
afternoon paper owned by U the Tribune
had been a Hearst paper in the Chicago
Tribune company bought it so it was an
afternoon paper and I was there at Super
Bowl 3 and it's an amazing story because
a group of us Jerry green was there from
Detroit s bu uh from
Dayton so we got in our cars I think we
took a couple taxis actually they were
staying at Lauderdale so we went up to
the hotel and in those day today if you
try to go into the hotel I like you're
going to get stopped at the door you're
not going in to see anybody from the
chiefs of the Niners but in those days
it was wide open so we went to the
Bellman and asked him you know is there
anybody around from the
Jets said hey neth is out back by the
pool B Bing out we go there were people
D like he was so accommodating there
were there were fans out there they were
they had surrounded his lounge chair and
um getting his autograph and asking him
about the game and he was just stretched
out in joy in the sunshine and so about
half dozen of us went out there and
interviewed him now he actually made the
promise that they were going to win uh
the night before at a dinner at a Galla
at a country club that's where he first
made it all right I was there with Dave
Anderson from The New York Times and my
wife we went we went out and had dinner
and he stood he said it kind of matter
of factly okay I guarantee we'll win
this game and it wasn't you know it it
later it sounded like it was bragado
doio but he didn't he didn't express it
that way just okay we're going to win
and and a way we spent uh out there at
poolside there's the famous picture of
us out there and oh we were out there
for a good hour with him and he finally
went had to go in for a meeting but um
Joe was always great with fans I mean
people even now he lives down in Jupiter
Florida when I lived down there and
people would stop him for his autograph
and that but I wonder if the Jets don't
win that game what happens what changes
if anything in the NFL AFL I'm not so
sure that the complete merger comes
about to tell you the truth I most
important game I call it the most
important game in the history of what we
now call the National Football League
okay the first game which I covered as a
writer was in the Los Angeles Coliseum
chiefs were there and they lost to Vince
Lombardi and the Packers Lombardi he
felt a lot of pressure Dan and he hid
the Packers up in Santa barbar and he he
made it clear to all of us stay away we
never talked to Lombardi before the game
Hank stram come on let's have a cocktail
in Long Beach you know what I'm saying
he he was he was entirely Vin worried
that if they lost to the AFL he he felt
the pressure of the entire National
Football League on his shoulders and we
later talked a long time about it and he
said he said it was the most pressure
he'd ever felt going into a game so all
right the NFL wins the first two okay
they they go down they win the second
one Packers and that was Vince's last
game when he beats the Raiders last game
as coach of the Packers so then we come
to Super Bowl
3 and because of what Vince had
accomplished the first two years uh all
the bookmakers out here made the Colts
an 18-point favorite okay an 18o favor
okay you talk about easy money if you
were a Jets fan okay and and you knew
Vinnie down in the bar or something you
know what I'm saying
so it was uh it was stunning Earl moral
Johnny Unitas both quarterbacking the
Colts couldn't get it done uh and and
the Jets won going away and now suddenly
that forces the hand we got to have a
complete merger between the old AFL and
the NFL it is the most important game in
the history of the league Bar None I
mean it it that and the first one
because the Packers were able to uh beat
the Chiefs in Super Bowl One we're
talking to Brett musberger the Hall of
Famer the state of where we are can you
have too much
football it's a good question um you
know we'll see what the ratings are with
the uh spring League coming up down we
we'll watch and see what eyeballs I mean
um I'm as amazed as these folks are out
here at uh what Taylor Swift was able to
accomplish with the ratings this year I
mean like the fact that she's around or
not it's irrelevant it it has been great
for the NFL it has been uh I I can't
believe how many youngsters now watch
the games because of her they follow her
and it's a demographic that's been added
to the league so
certainly certainly what we've come
through out of Co in that um I don't
think so right now not with the National
Football League and and of course the
commissioner announcing on Monday that
the Eagles are going to go down and be
one of they'll be the home team in
Brazil yeah on that Friday now there
that's another night you know Thursday
will be the opening the champion Sunday
will we host a game on Thursday but then
Friday the Eagles will host a game down
to Brazil and then on Sunday everybody
will be in action and there will be
finally a game on Monday one of our
favorite moments you were in the booth
with Kirk herb Street and Eminem came
into the
booth I was so hoping he'd make it to
the Super Bowl so we could have both he
and Taylor Swift sing the national
anthem you know I just thought that okay
how much did you know about Eminem when
he came into the
booth I knew his name and that was about
it okay well you kept calling him
matters oh yeah Ms Ms hey Ms how are you
Ms you know you know what was
interesting
Mathers uh he wasn't high now everybody
thinks he was because he came in he
standing between herb Street and me and
was not familiar with the monitors so he
was looking at himself and he kind of
froze on the on the camera and everybody
came oh Brent you had Eminem on and he
was so hot I said he wasn't you know he
oh no it was great we laugh I no now
that you tell me that cuz he's like
looking and his eyes are big his eyes
are huge and he's looking at himself
okay you know cuz we've got the monitors
there I thought he was he was having he
was kind of mocking you guys or like
messing with you guys no not at all not
at all he could have been nicer and also
he was he was a knowledgeable fan you
know and I and when you see him at the
Lions games and that he knows what's
going on out there so he wasn't high but
you and Herb Street were high when you
were doing the game that don't give away
my secrets these are my good friends out
here you know what I'm
saying you haven't done a gummy in a
while have yeah
right um we were wondering about a
Football Hall of Fame basketball has a
Basketball Hall of Fame so you can be a
great college player and go into the
Basketball Hall of Fame or great you
know you know then you or an NBA player
football doesn't have that would you
like to see a universal Football Hall of
Fame so Tim TBO is in the Hall of Fame
Cam Newton is in the Hall of Fame uh
Johnny Manzel would be in the Hall of
Fame because what they did in college
that's interesting I i' never I'd never
thought about it and uh because we have
Canton yeah for the NFL and and that's a
that's a wonderful Hall of Fame for
football are you in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame not that I know of I was on
Gummy when
I so contributions to the game you
started the pregame
show yeah that's an interesting story
because um would you like me to write a
letter on your
behalf I I did this for John Facenda
because I said it's a travesty that the
voice of the N is not in the Hall of
Fame and I give them credit they
responded to me and they put him in the
Hall of Fame you know what I'm going to
do that I'm going to I'm going to you
should be no I'm serious I would do that
thank you I would do that you should be
in the Pro you you were the first
pregame show Brent you've
been now I'm pissed off you know that
you're not in the whole them okay but
you know let me work on you let me work
on you should be in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame contributions to the game
you should be I I want to take you back
to the first pregame show that we did
okay as to how it started now can I take
a break sure and then we come back give
you a little bit more time sure okay all
right we'll come back we'll come back
with the future Pro Football Hall of
Famer Brent musberger right after this
in the damn Patrick
[Music]
Show
Hall of Famer and maybe one of these
days in the Pro Football Hall of Fame
Brett Musburger managing editor of bean
and countdown to kickoff with Brent
that'll be Sunday morning's noon Eastern
and it's the sports betting Network find
out more at
vs.com all right before the break you
were telling us when uh you started the
first pregame show yeah I we had um
announcers who went to the games to do
halftime and postgame yeah and I was one
and we got a call from the uh the head
of Sports at CBS Bob wesler and he said
Brent You Know Jack Whitaker and Pat
summer all tape a show on Friday okay he
said but I want to eliminate that and go
live for the 30 minutes okay and he said
do you know Irv cross and I laughed and
I said I know him very well because we
were at Northwestern together and I was
a u a gopher really for the daily
Northwestern the sports editor was upper
classman and so I would have to go get
quotes from coach era Paran who was
there before he went to Notre Dame and
Irv and I said Irv is a delightful
delightful man and I said heck of an
athlete so it was going to be the two of
us and about 6 weeks later I get a call
from Mr wler and he said Brent do you
know a Miss America by the name of
Phyllis Jord
and I go M I'm sorry but I really don't
follow the Miss America Pageant I said
if you ask me the quarterback is for the
Cults I might be able to tell you and he
said I want to bring her in on the show
now I'm I'm so I'm not going to say no
you know let's do it and it it was a
great addition because Irv and I had
rehearsed and practiced in halftime we
knew how to do the highlights and all
that but Phyllis was one of those
special person alties Dan she lit up a
room yeah and at that time there were no
women sports casters around okay there
was a Jane hastain was working at it
down in Miami and that was the only one
I remember but the folks the men in
particular they welcomed Phyllis on a
Sunday morning and she wound up being a
just a great host and um then the next
year the summer I get a call Brent do
you know a gambler by the name of Jimmy
the Greek and I said are you kidding
when I stopped by Las Vegas
of course I know the Greek I want to put
him on the show and I hesitated there
and I said where's the commission I
think oh we're going to have a meeting
with him he's going to be fine now the
one thing I knew about Pete Rosell I'd
always seen him at the Kentucky Derby I
knew he was a horse player and see him
at accur I said well he knows a little
bit about gambling so we had a
delightful Mee it was wler the Greek and
Brent over in Park Avenue the NFL office
could not have been nicer and we get up
to leave and he said um one thing he
said I'd like to ask a favor now when
the commissioner tells the three of us a
favor you know it's an order coming down
the line okay he said I want you guys
when you do your show please don't
mention minus three plus seven now okay
I'm thinking wait a minute that's that's
the whole point of this ex so but we all
say yes sir yes sir yes sir and on the
way back we said what are we going to do
and and we brought in some of the
technical people we rehearsed and they
managed to devise the checkboard for the
Greek people remember those early days
okay and if the Greek checked about four
on one side you knew it was cover seven
that team's going to cover the deal like
oh and then one day the about three
years later the Greek Greek took ill and
uh couldn't make the show we found out
on Saturday and I said well listen my
friend Pete Rose is in town and I knew
he liked to gamble on anything that
moved so I called Pete and I said Pete I
know this is bread I said listen to
favor can you come over and so he came
over and to this day when I run into him
he said you should have kept me I was a
better handicapper than the Greek okay
that was that was my guy Pete Rose
okay uh should Pete be in the Hall of
Fame absolutely and I would put an
asterisk at the bottom of it I think the
bottom of the plaque should read he was
suspended whatever the year was for
gambling on baseball I think it should
be in there um I I I don't think you
should ignore history and that's part of
History yeah and also you know if he bet
when he was playing then I understand
that if he manipulated games I know what
he did as a manager but I still have to
it's like when you cheat in grad school
I can't take away what you did in your
undergrad exactly and that's why you
know I look at Pete and those are two
separate things he is Brent musberger
Hall of Famer lead broadcaster managing
editor of Las Vegas stats and
information network uh visan the
original member of NFL today CBS and you
can learn more the uh sports betting
Network countdown to kickoff with Brent
musberger it's great to have you in as
always thank you ladies and gentlemen
what a St I do how about these people
get up morning out here right Jim N will
join us coming up next final hour on
this Wednesday Dan and the danet Marvin
fritzy Satan Paulie yours truly and a
great audience here at the fountain blue
tell